I forgot my keyboard
Auburn representative Osborne who moves
at the house adjourned from the session
of January 5th 2023. are you ready for
the question all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay the eyes have it
and the house is adjourned
the house will attend to a Prayer by
guest chaplain Reverend Father Paul M
Leary of the Diocese of New England and
Nova Scotia
Mr Speaker honorable members of the
House
let us be in the spirit of Prayer
almighty God we ask you a blessing on
all who have been chosen to chart the
costs of our great state
in whatever capacity each one serves be
the work great or seemingly unimportant
May each give their best
knowing that their place needs to be met
the test of loyalty and faith
if the purpose of our government is to
be fulfilled
when we read the history of our Granite
State
we know that if our leaders Through The
Years had not trusted Your Divine
Direction
we would not have obtained freedom and
remain free
Hold Us in your hands that we make that
you may keep us safe
we ask your blessing on all those who
serve
amen
and the Gaelic blessing
May the road rise up to meet your feet
May the wind always be at your back
May the sun shine warm upon your face
May the rain fall soft upon your field
and until we meet again
may God hold you in the palm of his hand
the chair recognizes the member from
Bedford representative Lauren Fox who
will lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance
the chair recognizes Christina Dyer and
Kristen Grant house committee
researchers who will now sing our
national anthem
foreign
[Music]
stripes and bright stars through the
perilous fight or the ramparts we
watched were so gallantly streaming and
the rockets red glare the bombs bursting
in air
gave proof through the night that our
flag was still there
oh saved us that Star Spangled
Banner yet wave
or the land of the free
and the home of the bridge
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
the house will attend to request for
leaves of absence
Mr Speaker the day illness
Representatives credian foot lewicki
McGee the day important business
Representatives Richard Brown conlon
Freitas muns Finney Prout Stringham
trottier verville the day illness in the
family representative Bradley
these leaves shall be granted unless
otherwise ordered by the house
the house will attend to introduction of
guests Mr Speaker please welcome
Catherine hirake and Desiree Porter
guests of Representative O'Neill Brian
McDonald father of Representative
Valerie McDonald there with us in the
gallery today
Welcome to the New Hampshire house
[Applause]
[Music]
the house will attend to a communication
Mr Speaker in a communication dated
January 5th 2023. Mr Paul Smith Clerk of
the house dear Paul please be advised
that the following Representatives elect
were sworn into office by the governor
and executive Council on this day koas
County district 6 William hatch Grafton
County District 3 Jerry Stringham and
Grafton County District 12 Mary Hagen
Phillips sincerely David M Scanlon
Secretary of State
Welcome to the New Hampshire house
[Applause]
the house will now attend to the consent
calendar
Mr Speaker from the committee on
executive departments and administration
House Bill 140 removed by
Representatives wheeler Montiel Horrigan
Gerhard yokela Alicia leckis Heath
Howard Tony leckis Ellen Reed and
Alessandra Murray from the committee on
Municipal and County government House
Bill 148 removed by representative
shewitt Edgar Lynn Doug Thomas Mark
Pearson Aaron Vose genesian and Steve
Steven Smith
also from the committee on Municipal and
County government House Bill 422 removed
by Representatives Ellen Reed wheeler
Santa nastasso yukela Tom Manion Newell
Horrigan Gallagher papovichi Mueller and
Heath Howard
are there any other bills to be removed
from the consent calendar
representative Osborne moves at the
consent calendar with the relevant of
amendments as printed in the day's house
record be adopted are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye all
those opposed nay the eyes have it and
the consent calendar is adopted
the house will now attend to the regular
calendar
the committee on executive departments
and administration to which was referred
House Bill 33 an act relative to
polycystic ovary syndrome awareness
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexperienced to
legislate representative Tony lakas for
the committee are you ready for the
question on the committee report of
inexperience legislative all those in
favor say aye all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
the majority of the committee on
executive departments and administration
which was referred to House Bill 94 an
act establishing October 2023 as eczema
Awareness Month having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is an
expedient to legislate representative
Jeffrey goalie for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same in being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the recommendation at the bill
Archer pass representative Diane schuett
for the minority of the committee the
question is on the majority report of an
experience of legislate are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
aye all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the report is
adopted
yep
the committee on executive departments
and administration which was referred
House Bill 230 FN an act directing the
Department of Agriculture markets and
food to employ an electronic data
processing system for all committee
question is on the committee report of
off to pass are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
all those opposed name
the eyes have it and the report is
adopted House Bill 230 is referred to
the committee on finance
the committee on executive department
said Administration which was referred
to House Bill 445 FN an act relative to
the operational funds of oplc having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation at the bill Ocha pass
representative Carol McGuire for the
committee the question is on the
committee report of Ocha pass are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the report is
adopted House Bill 445 is referred to
the committee on ways and means
the majority of the committee on
Municipal and County governments which
was referred House Bill 95 an act
enabling municipalities to adopt rental
practice regulations having considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that it is
an expedient to legislate representative
Diane power for the majority of the
committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same in being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass
for what reason does remember us
I Rise to make a motion
state in motion I Rise to table HB 95.
it's for a division vote
yes representative stavis moves that
house bill 95 be laid on the table
and request a division vote
members will take their seats
representative Hall request a roll call
is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded there shall
be a roll call vote members take your
seats
foreign
thank you
don't scare me
they also come to order
the question is whether to lay House
Bill 95 on the table this is a roll call
vote representative stavis is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that there is a
housing crisis in our state that
threatens our citizens businesses and
our status as one of the best places in
the nation to live
and if I know that skyrocketing rents
are fueling a large part of that crisis
and if I know Mr Speaker that in your
wisdom you have created a special
committee to delve deeply into this
problem and can consider the question of
rising rents in that holistic context
would I now press the green button to
support this tabling motion so the bill
can be improved and refined
thank you Mr Speaker
members are reminded to turn on your
voting stations
representative turcott is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker I rise in
opposition to the
Mr Speaker if I realize that this bill
came out of committee at a 16-3 vote for
I sorry about that
let's try that again
Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill came out of
committee with an ital recommendation of
16 to 3 and if I truly believe that that
is the motion that needs to be done
today would I now press the red button
on the tabling motion thank you
the question is whether to lay House
Bill 95 on the table this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor of cabling
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
foreign
have all members present had an
opportunity
to vote
all right now of all members president
had an opportunity to vote
the house will attend the state of the
vote
180 having voted in the affirmative 186
in the negative the motion fails
the questions now on the majority
committee report of inexped against the
legislate the member from Concord
representative Gallagher is recognized
to speak against the report
hello I'm Eric Gallagher the
representative from Concord Ward 6 which
is Merrimack County District 20 and I
rise today to speak in support of House
Bill 95 an act enabling municipalities
to adopt rental practice regulations so
s has was mentioned previously in the pi
we're in the housing and homelessness
crisis in this state so
how do people become homeless well one
of the ways
or one of one of the major drivers of
homelessness is when their landlords
evict them
and one of the things when I hear
when talking with constituents about our
housing and homelessness crisis is that
they're tired of their landlords raising
their rent on them
housing is a basic necessity for
everyone and the quality of housing can
have a significant impact on the health
and well-being of residents
um I
some of the constituents I've talked
with have actually had to move
I've I've lost neighbors due to being
driven out of conquered by Rising rents
um and we we've even had a school board
member here in Concord who's had to step
down from the school board
because she was evicted and then no was
no longer domiciled in the district that
she was supposed to be resent
representing so
with the large number of renters in my
district I decided to sign on to this
legislation as a co-sponsor to stand up
for them
so let's talk about what this
legislation does specifically it's
enabling legislation that enables
municipalities to adopt rental practice
regulations so the first part of that
being enabling legislation we're not
forcing any
municipalities to adopt
rental practice regulations we're merely
giving them the choice of whether they
want to do so or not
if rental practice regulations aren't a
good choice for a community then they
can simply vote not to adopt them
so yes I'm sure you've heard many times
New Hampshire is a Dylan rule state
rather than a home rule state so we have
to ask the legislature explicitly vote
to allow
give me a smile he said
[Music]
I apologize for that representative
the house will settle down you may
continue
um
so Ray I was talking about
um the whole part about enabling
legislation
um
so yeah that's the enabling legislation
part
as for the rental practice regulus
regulations part that might sound like
it's just a fancier term for rent
control but that's really just a small
part of
um
what falls under here it can also
include regulations on the notice given
before rent increases among other things
um
so let's address some of the
some of the
points raised in opposition to this bill
um
one is that it would constrain the
supply of Housing and
well we do also have other bills
coming through the legislature that will
help increase the supply of housing so I
think if we pass those as well and this
bill then the um any negative effects
this might have on Supply will cancel
out and we'll just get the benefits of
it of helping protect tenants from
eviction and causing them to become
homeless
um
so an another
another point
that was
raised in opposition
to this legislation was that
it will harm landlords who are housing
providers and well let's get something
straight about this landlords are not
housing providers the people the workers
who built the housing are the people who
actually provided it not the landlords
the landlords just sit on housing and
charge people rent to live in it they
deny people housing by default rather
than providing it to them so it would be
more accurate to call them housing
deniers than housing providers
so
um
so basically housing is a human right we
need to start treating as such rather
than as a profit making opportunity for
landlords
so let's enable let's stand up for
tenants
well it's enable municipalities to stop
feudalism in New Hampshire and please
join me in voting against the itl motion
on House Bill 95 so that another motion
may be made
thank you
the house recognizes a member from
Barrington representative Lynn surcott
to speak in support of the committee
report
Mr Speaker
I'm here to recommend the motion of itl
by the overwhelming majority of our
Municipal and County government
committee
HP 95 attempts to impose a rent control
by allowing towns and City politicians
to develop ways to regulate their rents
this would result in nothing more than a
patchwork of regulations throughout the
state
manipulating the marketplace by those
least qualified to do so just does not
work and it makes matters work worse by
distorting the free market
unfortunately like many other issues
that we encounter we look for the
instant gratification without
considering the long-term impact of
short-sighted ideas
now we have thousands of landlords in
New Hampshire that provide many
thousands of rental units
landlords are not the problem and in
fact I'm pretty sure throughout this
entire body there are many landlords in
here or who have been landlords
yet in testimony testimony we heard
comments such as fraud is being
committed
landlord commit landlords commit crimes
on society
landlords hoard housing lands landlords
are predatory
and even landlords are immoral
the comments insinuate that somehow the
thousands of landlords are colluding and
that is simply impossible when you have
so many landlords in our states
the other comment I'd like to make is
that it it was made during testimony was
it's up to the legislature to fix and no
it is not legislators cannot fix supply
and demand issues overnight
on issues that have taken decades and
decades to make
there are a few States
that have or allow rent control
and these will sound familiar to some of
you
California
New York New Jersey
Delaware
and Oregon recognize those States
those are the most fiscally
the states that are the most fiscal
basket cases in our country and they
also have the highest migration rates
out of there I also come to order
what was that about
remember making senior 37 States
actually have preemption laws against
rent control
now we heard much testimony from
landlords and Realtors actually who were
testifying on this and what would some
of the effects of actually rent control
be based on historical precedent
landlords will take units off the market
by converting their two three four unit
buildings back to single family or they
would just sell
Apartments will begin to deteriorate as
landlords no longer update or improve
their units for lack of funding
and apartment buildings or an apartment
buildings will cease they will investors
and landlords are not going to be
building
on new uh new units
without being under the whims of the
local politicians
and as one of the Realtors said who
testify this law would have the opposite
effect of what is intended
constraining housing will reduce quality
and quantity
so I thought if this is a good idea
what's the next logical step if the idea
is to keep the price of rental units
down
do we next allow
individuals and towns and cities
to exercise control over the selling
price of a building
the price of a building is Major
contribute
looks like we had a mic there we go it's
Pat
these are my popular boys
um
so yeah I mean is is that the next next
logical step are we going to start
giving legislators and politicians the
ability to you know set prices on what
you and I can sell our houses for or our
buildings for
well we got to understand that these
markets are cyclical and driven by
supply and demand the higher prices of
today will be driven lower
not into the distant future
we've seen this some of you actually
weren't even born in the late 80s and
early 90s but I can tell you New
Hampshire went through a massive crash
in the real estate market to the to the
point where over half of our banks in
this state went out of business because
it the prices crashed so so badly and
again 2008 not to the level of the late
80s and 90s but 2008 we saw the same
thing
so I'm going to wrap it up
Wise Guys
um
this is an instant gratification issue
we cannot simply fix the market forces
and supply and demand it has to run its
course this and other housing issues is
not something we can fix overnight it's
going to take decades to fix or at least
a long time because it's taken decades
to occur prices do not only go up they
go down and they will
those buying inflated prices by the way
back in the 80s in the 2008 time frame
who overpaid for their properties
sustained foreclosures they lost things
so the cyclical Nation nature will bring
it back politicians bureaucrats not the
ones to alleviate these housing problems
those in the rental and business
building business are the ones who have
eventually solved the issue
landlords provide thousands and
thousands of units in this state
and lastly rent control is a historical
failure no matter where it's been tried
and it's not how we in New Hampshire do
business thank you Mr Speaker and I do
request a roll call vote
does a member yield for a question I do
not
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
representative for taking the question
representative Harrington the member
does not yield
representative turcott requests a roll
call vote is that sufficiently seconded
that is sufficiently seconded this will
be a roll call vote members take your
seats
shall come to order the question is on
the majority committee report of inexped
into legislate this will be a roll call
vote
representative priest is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry members should be
in their seats
Mr Speaker
if I know a third of the state residents
are renters that are facing a rental
market with vacancy rates of less than
0.11 percent
and their rental rates have increased in
the last three years more than 70
percent
if I know that hundreds of elderly and
disabled people
veterans and families are being
displaced from their homes because of
the escalating Reds
and if I know that HB 95 is enabling
legislation not a mandate which allows
local control
of the decision
would I now press the red button so that
we can allow municipalities
to deal with this emergency as soon as
possible
thank you
the questions on the majority committee
report of an expedient to legislate
representative Lynn turcott is
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that rent
control has been a failure wherever it's
been implemented and if I also know that
rents are a function of Supply demand
and not a case of hoarding fraud
immorality conspiracy or crimes of
society by landlords and finally Mr
Speaker if I know that passing this bill
will have the opposite effect of its
intentions and cause thousands of New
Hampshire landlords that provide
thousands of rental units to reconsider
whether
to to consider whether to remove rental
units from the market would I then press
the green button in support of the
motion of itl thank you Mr Speaker
the question is on the majority
committee report of index speed against
the legislate this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll be pressing
the green button if you're opposed
you'll be pressing the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
of all members presence had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
301 having voted in the affirmative 63
and the negative the committee report is
adopted
house will be in order Representatives
Wilhelm and selig declared conflicts and
did not participate in the vote
the majority of the committee on
Municipal and County governments which
was referred House Bill 295 FN and act
relative to requiring all select board
and school board meetings to be recorded
and broadcast live online having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
it is inexped into legislate
representative Tim Cahill for the
majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation of the bill ought to pass
representative Laurel stavis for the
minority of the committee
for what reason does remember rise
[Music]
of State emotion
the table
and a vote
representative stavis moves to lay a
house bill 295 on the table
and request a division vote this will be
a division vote members take their seats
foreign
is
it
the question is whether to lay a house
bill 295 on the table
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll be pressing the green
button if you're opposed you'll be
pressing the red button voting stations
are open for 30 seconds
foreign
[Music]
a Merchants
representative merchants
can't push the buttons closed thumbs up
or thumbs down please
thumbs up or thumbs down please thank
you
representative Perez representative
thumbs up or thumbs down the boat is
closed thank you
alrighty of all members presence had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend the state of the
vote
322 having voted in the affirmative 45
in the negative House Bill 295 is laid
on the table
the Committee on Public Works and
highways to which was referred House
Bill 412 an act re-establishing a
commission to study Revenue alternatives
to the road show for funding of
improvements to the state highways and
bridges and their resulting improvements
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation at the bill
ought to pass representative John
Cloutier for the committee the question
is on the majority committee report of
off to pass you ready for the question
all in favor say aye
all those opposed name
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
the committee on state federal relations
and Veterans Affairs to which was
referred House Bill 330 FNA an act
relative to the National Guard
recruitment incentive program and its
funding and rulemaking having considered
the same report the same with the
recommendation at the bill ochsa pass
representative skip Rollins for the
committee
the question is on the majority
committee report about to pass are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
all those opposed name
the guys have it and the committee
report is adopted House Bill 330 FNA is
referred to the committee on finance
the house will now it's in to Bill's
removed from the consent calendar
the committee on executive departments
and administration which was referred
House Bill 140 and act proclaiming
January 24th as granny D-Day having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
it is in expedient to legislative
representative Jackie grota for the
committee
the member from Durham representative
Horrigan is recognized to speak against
the committee report
my bad the member from Peterborough
representative wheeler is recognized to
speak against the committee report
fun
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you to
members of the house I want to start off
by giving deference to my friends on
Edna I have respect for the consensus
decision that you make on bills like
these but for this one I disagree Doris
haddock was a woman born a hundred years
ago 113 years ago
just two weeks she
Doris haddock born in 1910
in her life she saw many things booms
and busts of the economy a Great
Depression social upheaval
assassinations some of the greatest
music and most exciting moments in human
history she saw a nation in Decline the
wish for kings taking over the
politicians that she had entrusted with
her nation and to try and oppose that
fact she stood up and did everything she
could as a teenager she was an
environmentalist hanging herself to
trees to try and stop the for the
forestation of our forests and as an old
woman she walked thirty two hundred
miles across this country to try and
stop campaign Finance reform from
happening in the form of citizens united
stood up every day to make sure that
people across this country knew that our
country was being bought out and sold by
billionaires and corporations who did
not care about us nor our country and
Doris haddock not a politician not a
person who was partisan in it by any
means
tried to get all of us to recognize that
fact tried to get all of us to recognize
that what no matter what side you're on
left or right our country is being
bought and sold by corporations who do
not care about us I think Doris haddock
is exactly the kind of Citizen we should
be honoring here in this state I think
someone who stood up for what they
believe in whether or not you agreed
with everything she said someone who
walked 3 200 miles to try and get people
to focus on an issue of campaign Finance
reform that is exactly the type of
Citizen that we should be honoring in
this body
someone who stands up and tries to get
people involved a citizen who does
everything that they can in their power
to try and get the nation in which she
lives to focus on the values which it
purports to hold that to me is
the American dream it's being an
American citizen it's the beauty of
having the freedom that is owed to us as
an American and honoring granny D her
113 year old woman who lived from 1910
to 2010 by saying this is a woman who we
should live up to I think is exactly
what this house should be doing so thank
you Mr Speaker for allowing me to speak
I apologize I couldn't read too well off
of my phone but let's honor granny D
let's honor Doris by saying that we
should be
making January January 4th uh her day I
think that's a worthwhile thing for this
house to do thank you Mr Speaker
the member from Durham representative
Horrigan is recognized to speak against
the committee report thank you very much
Mr Speaker I can skip most of my speech
because uh representative the
representative from Peterborough covered
the same ground um I
I was one of the people who actually
actually knew her I think she's probably
the greatest person I've ever met in my
life and I speak as somebody who's met
Jimmy Carter and Joey Ramone and a few
other notable people over the years
I'm not nobody special I'm just old and
and um in fact people believe in ghosts
occasionally think sometimes you can
even see her ghost up in the up in the
gallery unfortunately I don't see it now
but um
do you still alive in my memories I was
one of the several members of people
here in the room who attended her 100th
birthday party it was just around the
corner in the executive Council chamber
100 years is it's a lot more years than
most people get but it's still a pretty
short time and she made the most of it
and we heard just a sampling of the many
incredible things she did in those
hundred years
um she was 10 years old in 1920 when
women got the right to vote and she made
a point of asking a 10 year old girl to
introduce her 13 years ago right around
the corner from here in the executive
Council chamber and I don't remember the
exact date but it was in February
almost exactly almost exactly to the day
and it was actually at the same time of
day that we're now here about uh 11 A.M
so
she was reminding us to pass was not
that long ago the future is already here
and the fight for justice never ends and
so I think
she deserves to be commemorated with the
day every year and so I think I think
she deserves to be singled out as one of
the causes that we celebrate every year
whether or not the governor
chooses the issue a proclamation not as
every Governor I will have to admit who
served since she passed has done so so I
I receive me to overturn the itl so we
can move on to a another motion so thank
you
the member from representative grotta is
recognized to speak for the committee
report
thank you Mr Speaker and I thank the
previous speakers for sharing their
passion with us about granny d
and I have no doubt that she was a
magnificent person and contributed in
magnificent ways to the history of New
Hampshire
so if you feel that way do something
about it
commemorate her have a parade give her a
birthday party in Laconia do all these
things but do not relegate her to a
single line in an RSA that will sit in
the shelf of our lob for the remainder
of time
put her someplace where you care
thank you please support the committee
of itl on the house bill 140.
house will be in order
the question is on the committee report
of an expediential legislate are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes Abbott and the committee
reporters
foreign
[Music]
very efficient as well
the committee on Municipal and County
government so which was referred House
Bill 148 an act to raise the minimum
value of County purchases of equipment
or materials which are subject to
competitive bidding having considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that it is
in expedient to legislate representative
Diane power for the committee
for what reason does a member rise
arise to make a motion
please State your motion
representative Sanborn moves that house
bill 148 be laid on the table are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
all those against nay
the eyes have it and House Bill 148 is
laid on the table
all right
the committee on Municipal and County
governments which was referred House
Bill 422 FM an act to create a public
County registry of the monthly rent
charged by landlords for each owned unit
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that it is in expedient to
legislate representative Julie Gilman
for the committee
for what reason doesn't remember us
make a motion Mr Speaker please State
your motion I emotion
[Music]
representative Reid moves at House Bill
422 be laid on the table for what reason
does remember rise I Rise for emotions
to speak
State your motion I make a motion of
indefinitely postponing
swing and a miss
the emotion is to lay House Bill 422 on
the table are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
tell those proposed nay
[Music]
I gotta grab this faster the chairs and
the chairs kind of in doubt but this
will be a division clarification vote
nobody and nobody out
and members protect your seats on a
clarification vote there's no pis
see
the question is whether to lay House
Bill 422 FN on the table this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
foreign
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend the state of the
vote
163 in the affirmative 200 in the
negative the motion fails
the question before the house is the
majority committee report of an
expedience allegedly are you ready for
the for what reason does remember rise
to make a motion State your motion I
move to indefinitely postpone
representative hole moves that we
indefinitely postpone House Bill 422 are
you ready for the question
division's been requested this will be a
division vote members take your seats
clearly has
right so we have a lot of new peoples
who explain the motion
and definitely postpone in a nutshell
means if that passes
done for the term without a suspension
of rules that lay on the table you can
always take it back off the table and
definitely postpone that that's it
the question is whether to indefinitely
postpone House Bill 422 this is a
division vote
representative Asherton is recognized
for a parliamentary inquiry
[Music]
thank Mr Speaker if I know that I serve
on the house Select Committee for
housing and if I know that there was
broad bipartisan agreement to ensure
that we try to save as many housing
bills as possible so that we have all
the tools available as the speaker
requested to look into that issue this
year and if I know that I want to honor
that commitment would I then ask the
house to oppose the indefinite
postponement motion so that the select
housing committee has all resources
available to try to tackle this
important crisis
and for clarification the New Hampshire
also special committees
representative Lynn turcott is
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know this bill
was itailed in the municipal and County
government committee by a vote of 1901
and if I forward further know that it is
a clear unfunded mandate
and if I know this bill is completely
unworkable due to its lack of details
would I now press the green button to
indefinitely postpone
the question is whether to indefinitely
postpone House Bill 422 Mr division vote
if you're in favor of indefinitely
postponed you will press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
[Music]
of all members presence had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
206 having voted in the affirmative 158
and the negative House Bill 422 is
indefinitely postponed
the chair recognizes a member from
Auburn representative Osborne for the
third reading motion
resolved that the house now adjourned
from the early session that the business
of the late session be in order at the
present time that the reading of bills
be by title only and resolutions by
caption only and that all bills ordered
a third reading be read a third time by
this resolution and that all titles of
bills be the same as adopted and that
they be passed at the present time and
when the house adjourns today it be to
meet Tuesday February 14 2023 at 10 A.M
the question is on the third reading
motion are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed name the eyes have it
and the motion is adopted
representative Carol McGuire is
recognized for an announcement
thank you Mr Speaker to the members of
Edna house we will exec House Bill 109
next Tuesday with the other bills we're
executing thank you
representative Vos has recognized for an
announcement
I apologize uh Mr Speaker I did not hear
my name called
on Monday this past Monday
a Committee Member
was struck him down ill and was unable
to attend an executive session so we
postponed the executive sessions on Two
Bills House Bill 418 and House Bill 92
to this Friday at 4 pm
thank you
representative Ladd is recognized for an
announcement
Mr Speaker immediately following the
right to life caucus scheduled for noon
today we will have the education
committee caucus of Republicans in room
205. thank you
representative Grossman is recognized
for an announcement
thank you Mr Speaker hi everyone I'm
Gabby Grossman I chair the bipartisan
disability caucus and today from noon
till 1 30 there will be a meet and greet
in the cafeteria with various
stakeholders
different groups from the disability
Community please join us there will be
sandwiches cookies lots of food so come
join us 12 to 1 30 in the cafeteria
thank you
representative Wayne McDonald's is
recognized for an announcement
thank you Mr Speaker this afternoon
Health and Human Services and elderly
Affairs will be meeting an executive
session at 1 30 to take up a number of
bills in addition to those that have
been noticed we'll also be taking up a
house Bill 47. thank you
representative Weiler is recognized for
an announcement
thank you Mr Speaker I actually have two
announcements tomorrow
division three of the finance committee
will be having a work session on House
Bill 49 at 11 o'clock 2 10 to 11. Second
announcement Brotherhood of free and
accepted masons if you are here and you
are a Masons we're going to have a
meeting on the third floor in the
conference room
go up after you get to the top of the
elevator the top of the stairs go
straight ahead and there's a conference
room want to have a quick meeting of
Masons please join us thank you
the house clerk is recognized for an
announcement thank you Mr Speaker uh for
those of you if you have items in your
seat Pockets please take them with you
we have several committee hearings
happening in here next week so please do
not leave anything in your seat Pockets
if you have not emptied your mailboxes
in the back of the chamber please do so
as well as some of those are filling up
rather full pretty quickly and we want
to make sure that we don't have to
put a mail forwarding service in for you
thank you
Josh will attend a request for unanimous
consent
the chair recognizes representative
Wendy Thomas
for a thank you
colleagues
as my committee chair likes to refer to
me I am the representative Wendy Thomas
and I come before you to share my thanks
to some people in this room who helped
me through a pretty rough last two years
I look a little different from the last
time some of you have seen me there are
reasons for that
in November of 2020 I got a virus that
left me with ongoing symptoms I couldn't
smell or taste food for about two years
I also had no appetite or sense of
thirst
I lost a lot of weight
I wrote about my experiences and some of
my friends former and current
legislators senators and even some staff
who knew me when I had been a rep
reached out and followed along
although the condition left me in
precarious health I was grateful that I
wasn't as bad as some other people in
the same position
as sick as I was I was able to see the
humorous side
I sure was a lot of fun at holiday
parties when everyone played the game
give Wendy the candle and let her tell
us what it smells like
I couldn't identify one
I was sick but I was coping
but then last year in May on May 19th I
was diagnosed with cancer
I started documenting my journey in a
private group and let my trusted friends
some of whom are sitting in this Hall
into that private Circle
if you know me you know that I didn't
hold anything back
they heard the Bad and the Ugly
there is very little good to report
about cancer
they heard my fears and my outrage at
how unfair it all was
they heard me struggle to try to make
sense of anything
oh boy
at the beginning I was so cocky I was
ready to eat the right food and do the
right exercises I was going to beat this
cancer I was going to teach people how
to do cancer right
but here's a little life secret no one
can do cancer alone no one it is simply
too big
some people would have left me it's too
painful to watch it's too much it's too
scary but these friends my legislative
friends who had met me years before here
at the State House continued being my
friends
they stayed with me the entire time
I had one horrific operation followed by
horrific pain followed by horrific
complications followed by another
horrific surgery followed by more
horrific pain all of this on top of the
constant Terror and threat of living and
maybe even dying with cancer
I stumbled I fell
I dissolved into a wet heap of tissue
and Bone again and again
and each time from my friends my
legislative friends and you know who you
are
I heard we are here for you
borrow our strength until you can find
your own again
and you are loved
each time I fell I honestly didn't think
I'd be able to get back up again
it was asking too much of me
I am just one little person yes I am
mighty but some things are mightier
but like a mother's prayer I kept
hearing from my friends we are here for
you borrow our strength until you can
find your own again and you are loved I
took Grace from their presence
and just like they offered I borrowed
from their strength until I could stand
on my own again
and I knew deep in my bones that I was
loved
because of my friends I was able to get
back up again and again
I'm doing okay not completely out of the
woods yet but I'm doing okay
it is not hyperbole to say that some
members of this body Lifted Me and
helped to save both me and my family
to those members I am eternally grateful
so to wrap this up
to the new legislators
my wish for you is to find the kinds of
friendships bonds and support that I was
able to find
it's here Within These Walls Within this
Brotherhood and Sisterhood you just have
to look
it is a gift and it will change your
life
and to my friends current legislators
former legislators senators and even
some staff up here at the State House
You Know Who You Are
but more importantly I Know Who You Are
I am forever in debt to your kindness
and support
this is my promise to you
that when the day comes when you stumble
and fall
I will say to you
I am here for you
borrow my strength until you can find
your own again
and I will tell you over and over and
over that you are so very loved
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
reason doesn't remember us
Mr Speaker I asked that the gentle
gentleman so ordered
representative wrong is recognized for
unanimous consent regarding lung cancer
early detection
thank you Mr Speaker and dear colleagues
while substituting in an executive
departments and administration committee
executive session a few weeks ago I
learned a great deal from our esteemed
colleague from Grafton 12.
representative Mary hacken Phillips
about the critical importance of early
screening for lung cancer
early screening can turn a terminal
diagnosis into one with optimism for a
full recovery in fact one of our own
representative Kat McGee of Hollis is
now recovering from surgery where the
early detection of lung cancer will
likely save her life and preserve its
quality
November of this year is National Lung
Cancer Awareness Month but I implore you
to make every month in which you
appreciate the importance of early
screening and how it can extend our
lives and the lives of our loved ones
thank you
[Applause]
representative madraputi is recognized
for unanimous consent regarding Harvest
Festival
thank you Mr chair thank you to my
esteemed colleagues here to let me share
um this wonderful Festival that I have
shared before in this house and there
are a lot of new people in this and
there's a treat associated with it when
you go out there is packets of Trail Mix
that I'll talk about why this Festival
is very important this festival called
Makara sankranti or it's a Hindu
festival celebrated in almost all parts
of India and Nepal
sankranti marks the transition of the
sun into the zodiac sign on on its
Celestial path
marking the end of the month with the
winter solstice and the start of a
longer days it's a celebration of
arrival of spring in India
sankranti is also a solar event
making it one of the few Indian
festivals which fall on the same date in
the Gregorian calendar
every year on 14th of January with some
exceptions when the festival is
celebrated either on the 13th or the
15th of January there is a significance
to that January 16th is Martin Luther
King Day his birthday so there's an
association
sankranti also known as Pongal marks the
day that the sun begins its northern
movement and harvest is brought in on
this day friends and family are offered
a mixture of jaggery which is the raw
sugar and sesame which is still as well
as sugar cane and various lentils
jaggery is sweet and is a symbol of love
till or the Sesame is known as sneha or
friendship therefore the offering of
jaggery Sesame mixed mixture signifies
love and friendship
the message is building Community
fostering love friendship and Harmony
you heard how important it is for all of
us as human beings
and so this brings me to why do I take a
lot of effort and time to do this to
share my Heritage or this Festival the
part that building Community is very
important to me growing up that was what
made me feel
drawn to this Festival
so this community building existed very
early not in you know today we have a
lot of social media instant uh sharing
of stuff but
since I got elected to this body
I have celebrated or shared this with my
colleagues here because it signifies how
Martin Luther King in my I am growing up
in India shared a lot of thing with
Gandhi who led a lot of Civil
Disobedience and you know fought for the
freedom of many people not just in India
but also in South Africa who was he
influenced by none other than our
neighbor who grew up in or was from
Massachusetts henrid Henry David Thoreau
his Civil Disobedience was what
influenced Gandhi and he followed him
very closely and when he was fight
Gandhi was fighting for freedom in India
through Civil Disobedience and
non-violence and none other than and
Martin Luther King was influenced by
Gandhi and they had many correspondents
both Henry David Thoreau and Gandhi and
then Gandhi and Martin Luther King so
this brings full circle to me to have
this distinct honor of being able to
share this that building community
across the globe across the oceans in my
own little Community within my state and
within my community called Nashua and
where the diversity ethnic diversity
that is celebrated and included and with
that there's uh Li some packets of this
trail mix that I've put in the ante room
so please help yourself and remember we
are building Community one heart at a
time one person at a time and thank you
namaste
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
representative Rosner is recognized for
unanimous consent regarding an apology
and Tyree Nichols
thank you Mr Speaker firstly I want to
extend my genuine apologies to you Mr
Speaker and to the chamber for walking
in front of the well and disrupting our
process earlier I clearly did not think
my actions through before moving my body
and I hope that this mistake serves as a
powerful lesson to all of the freshmen
present today
laughs
[Music]
in addition I wanted to speak on a
recent event on January 7th 2023 in
Memphis Tennessee 29 year old Tyrese
Nichols was fatally beaten during a
traffic stop and I invite you to join me
in a moment of silence to honor the life
and dignity of Tyree Nichols
[Applause]
foreign
thank you
representative Osborne moves at the
house stand and recess for the purposes
of the introduction of bills and
receiving messages are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it and
the motion is adopted those who voted
nay can hang out for a while
the house is in recess until
February 14
2023 at 10 A.M